Speaker 1: So this you really have to see
to believe this, this is just out of this
world, a bizarre.
Tucker Carlson, the Fox News propagandist,
has been promoting a forthcoming, then forthcoming
special on masculinity and testosterone that
is going to, I guess, shed light on the crisis
of masculinity that Tucker says exists and
talk about the issues with decreased testosterone
in men, which we will get to in a moment.
And it's all really weird.
And one of the things that many people noticed
about the promo for the thing was that it's
quote Homo erotic.
Now again like to say it's to say something
is homo erotic pejoratively is kind of homophobic,
and I don't think that's what the commentaries
were here.
It's pointing out this is all about restoring
men in the image that Tucker Carlson and other
right wingers see men as being expected to
hold.
And yet the promo seemed much more in line,
maybe with, I don't know, with with gay men.
It's not even really clear like exactly what
the commentary was, but I'm going to play
the promo for you, and it is certainly strange.
It doesn't exactly seem like the prototypical
alpha male idea of Tucker's audience, so take
a look at this to start with.
So there's like a there was like a naked guy
with like a light on his testicles and then
now there's now there's like half naked guys
exercising
Speaker 4: once a society collapses, he said.
You were in hard times as well.
Hot iron sharpens iron, as they say, and those
hard times inevitably produce men who are
tough men who are resourceful men who are
strong enough to survive.
And then they go on to reestablish order.
And so the cycle begins again.
Speaker 1: The end of men is the is the name
of it and it all.
If I told if you told me, David.
Check out this satire of a Fox News special
about masculinity and you showed me that I'd
go, Wow, that's a really funny satire, but
it's real.
So the special has aired, and there was a
fitness expert brought on to explain how to
raise testosterone levels in men.
And the topic comes up of testicle tanning,
tanning your testicles.
Speaker 4: You saw in the clip there, if you
want to optimize and take it to another level,
expose yourself to red light therapy.
Yes.
And the juice that we were using in the documentary,
there was a massive amount of testicle tanning.
It's testicle tanning, but it's also full
body.
Red light therapy has massive amount of benefits,
and there's so much data out there that isn't
being picked up on our covered.
Speaker 2: So obviously half the viewers right
now are like what that's called testicle Jane.
That's crazy.
But my view is OK.
Testosterone levels like crash and nobody
says anything about it.
That's crazy.
So why is it crazy to seek solutions?
Speaker 4: It's not crazy to seek solutions,
and I think I was recently exposed to a term
called homeopathy.
And I think there's a lot of people out there
right now that are don't trust the mainstream
information.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, I wouldn't call it bro myopathy.
I think what he's looking for is Bromium apathy
like homeopathy.
Either way, it's not very funny.
Now, to be clear, red light therapy for testosterone
is being studied, and there are reports saying
it might do something or it might not.
But this isn't even a doctor.
This is a guy branded a fitness professional,
and the entire thing is so bizarre and they
always bring in this undertone.
We can't trust the official stuff.
What we're being told can't be believed.
So therefore you got to start tanning your
balls, bro.
And the next guest afterwards was Kid Rock,
the right wing musician, and he even Kid Rock
was like, Is this all a joke?
That's when, you know, it's weird when even
Kid Rock can't take it seriously.
Speaker 2: OK, ladies and gentlemen.
So are our cameraman.
Scott Fox is in your house right now.
He is due to stop testicle tanning.
Come on.
Yeah.
Yeah, I haven't heard anything yet, but when
you're talking on your mind body, I'm starting
a punk rock band and it's called testicle
tanning.
That's the end of it.
I think you'll be massively successful.
But I mean, do you think at this point when
so many of the therapies, the paths they've
told us to take have turned out to be dead
ends that have really hurt people?
Speaker 1: Why is Kid Rock being interviewed
about this?
Like Kid Rock doesn't know anything about
media literacy.
Kid Rock doesn't know anything about medicine.
It's a crazy premise to bring on Kid Rock
to comment on Testicle Tanning Fitness Pro.
Speaker 2: I wouldn't open minded people seek
new solutions.
I don't know what the Hell's going on in this
world.
I'm not even sure if I understood that question,
but some days I just want to stop.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
No, he didn't.
Kid Rock doesn't even understand the question
that Tucker Carlson is asking him now.
Let's interject some reality here.
A good question is, are the premises even
true?
Our testosterone levels decreasing now?
The answer is yes, but it's not exactly clear
why or what it means.
So there's been a bunch of studies done over
several decades.
And it does appear as though testosterone
levels are decreasing in men at a given age
like we know about over time in for an individual
as one ages, testosterone levels decrease.
But there is something different going on,
which is men of a particular age today seem
to have slightly lower testosterone levels
than men of the same age at some period in
the past, so it appears to be decreasing.
Then the question is why and the cause is
not actually known, but there is a bunch of
different ideas.
One aspect of this could be external toxins
and something environmental.
We know that there's lots of products out
there that have endocrine disruption potential.
And we know certain things can affect female
fertility, so there could be things in the
environment that affect men's testosterone
levels.
That's one possibility.
Another piece appears to be untreated depression.
We have pretty good data that untreated depression
pushes down testosterone levels.
We have both stigma around mental health treatment
in the United States, as well as lack of access
to mental health treatment in the United States.
You don't treat depression.
If depression decreases decreases testosterone,
you would expect to see decreased testosterone.
Obesity is very high in the United States,
and moderate obesity seems to diminish testosterone
due to what's called insulin resistance associated
reductions in the sex hormone binding globulin.
OK, so that that maybe obesity may be a factor
here.
Men with diabetes are more likely to have
low testosterone.
It's not clear whether it's a cause effect
correlation causation.
So there is an issue and it's being explored
by medical doctors.
Decrease in testosterone.
But Tucker's friends, Kid Rock and a fitness
professional aren't going to be the ones to
solve it.
They're also not the authorities on this.
And maybe the most important thing is they
frame this as a cultural issue of sissy men,
like when the right talks about the end of
men and decreased testosterone, they're talking
about sissy men, men that don't meet the prototypical
emblematic image of what a manly man is supposed
to be.
What's particularly funny is Tucker doesn't
meet that standard either, right?
I mean, like, like, I don't care about these
standards and these ideas.
But Tucker, as the privileged sort of, you
know, I think dandy might be the word that's
that's applied bow tie wearing.
I mean, he had, you know, tasseled in that
interview.
He had tasseled.
You can even kind of see it tasseled loafers
with no socks like he.
He's not the guy that meets.
Neither is Trump, right?
And so that's what's also very strange about
this now, just as a bonus clip.
Here's a preview of another upcoming Tucker
Carlson special, where he brings on two butchers
to talk about the idea that extraterrestrials
are mutilating cattle.
This is the next special.
Speaker 4: You have to have the right tools,
so and you have to have the right knife with
the right edge on it, because if you don't
have a sharp knife, you're never going to
be able to achieve, you know, you might be
able to achieve it.
But but it's going to look like you didn't
know what you were doing.
So if these animals have been found with their,
you know, these pieces surgically removed
and, you know, not making a lot of hack marks
when you're cutting, somebody knows what they're
doing, right?
Speaker 2: So that that's it to assess the
difficulty here.
So